in 1987 a man you never heard of named
stephen hoffenberg met with everyone's
favorite person the infamous jeffrey
epstein their plan to build the biggest
ponzi scheme the world has ever seen
this was before epstein had a private
island and probably before his operation
with underage girls began in the way
these two were introduced by a british
arms dealer in intelligence assets sir
douglas lease almost immediately epstein
and hoffenberg hit it off they shared an
obsession with making money at all costs
and to hoffenburg epstein was a genius
with quote no moral compass end quotes
exactly the guy he was looking for
together the dynamic duo joined forces
in hoffenberg's company called towers
financial corporation a very unassuming
name that doesn't make you think twice
and they turned it into a multi-billion
dollar enterprise they traveled the
world together wanting and dining
investors selling bonds and doing
everything respectable businessmen are
expected to do outside the company was
marketed as a debt collection agency but
on the inside it was a classic ponzi
scheme
by 1993 hoffenberg and epstein has
scammed over 200 000 investors out of
450 million dollars almost a billion
dollars in today's money they had stolen
from everyone teachers the elderly
businesses you name it they scammed it
at the time it was the biggest ponzi
scheme in history it wouldn't be for
another 10 years until bernie madoff
came along and took that title away from
them they made millions and when the
scheme was finally exposed hoffenberg
took the fall and went to prison but
epstein he escaped without a single
charging up to a hundred million dollars
in the bank
the worst financial fraud in history at
the time made epstein a nine-figure
millionaire and he got off without
warning and many believe that this is
where epstein got his initial money that
this ponzi scheme was to see money the
nest egg that epstein would use to fund
his most infamous business yet an
international operation recording the
most powerful people in the world
committing some of the most heinous
crimes a man can convince
if it wasn't for this ponzi scheme
epstein may never have gotten the
initial boost he needed to finagle his
way into the upper echelons of society
this is the tower's financial ponzi
scheme
[Music]
traditionally if you were looking at
getting access to the best investments
or asset managers you had to be rich
famous or the target of a ponzi scheme
the best guys on wall street have always
ignored everyday investors because they
just won't make any money from you in
fees getting any sort of attention on
wall street required you to already be
ultra wealthy and for a group of smart
people that didn't sit well so they
created titan the premier investment
manager for the rest of us
it's the world's first direct to
consumer investment platform for people
who want their money actively managed by
an award-winning investment team and
titan already manages over 750 million
dollars for 50 000 plus clients just
like you all you have to do to get
started is head to the link below down
the app sign up deposit the 100 minimum
and boom you get access to award-winning
investment strategies for everything
from u.s based stocks international
stocks to crypto assets tyne's
time-tested unique strategy of
identifying the rare species of stocks
known as compounders and honing on
tights allows them to aim to grow your
investments 15 annually which would
imply doubling your wealth every five
years net a fees the firm offers zero
performance fees no lockups and a flat
rate advisory fee all it takes is a
hundred dollars to get started on your
journey towards smart investing with a
company that's been listed as a forbes
next billion dollar startup and a 2021
top fintech startup go to titan.com jake
and get your first three months of
expert investment management for zero
fees that's titan.com jake for three
months free
[Music]
towers financial corporation was created
in the 1970s by hoffenberg as a debt
collection agency here's what that means
people will end up owing money to things
like hospitals phone companies and banks
but they wouldn't pay hospitals phone
companies and banks would try to chase
them down for the money but it would be
a lot of work and after a while they
would just give up on it so instead of
just losing all the money these
companies would sell that debt to a debt
collection agency like towers financial
corporation for pennies on the dollar
the debt collection agency would then
work their magic to collect the money
from those people and since they bought
the debt for pennies on the dollar any
money they did collect would be very
profitable or at least that's what
towers financial was doing on the
outside
to outsiders stephen hoffenberg was the
epitome of the american dream he started
his business with just two thousand
dollars and turned it into an almost 100
million dollar business and looked like
american entrepreneurship at its finest
it even had a couple of subsidiaries
also involved in the debt collection
business
compared to other businesses in the same
industry towers was generally an under
the radar small time corporation that no
one paid any attention to that was until
our friend epstein joined the team then
things went downhill fast
when epstein joined towers in 1987 as
stephen hoffenberg's right-hand man the
company started making some big moves
they bought two illinois insurance
companies sold bonds from the companies
to investors and used that money to try
to take over an airline pan american
airways ultimately the deal failed and a
lot of money was lost but strangely
enough hoffenberg and epstein didn't
face any real backlash the investors
didn't complain too much and this got
them thinking if they could get away
with losing millions of their investors
money why couldn't they lose that money
into their own pockets if nothing
happened after the pan am disaster what
if they could continue losing money on
failed business deals while really
pocketing the money for themselves
they could make millions
and with towers financials long-standing
reputation as a real debt collection
agency it would be like taking candy
from a baby so a ponzi scheme was born
[Music]
in order to get people interested in
investing in a ponzi scheme you need to
make it look legit and that's exactly
what towers financial appeared to be by
1987 the company had been around for 17
years it had a clean track record minus
the pan am disaster but overall it
looked like a perfectly trustworthy
business
one of the ways towers made money was
through bonds it was sell a bond to an
investor promising to pay them a certain
amount of interest over a period of time
then on a specified date after paying
all the interest towers would pay back
the investor's original money it's a
practice used by many companies all over
the world to raise money to expand their
business but according to hoffenberg he
and epstein saw an opportunity like
never before what if they could cook the
books a little bit you know fudge the
numbers to make it seem like they were
making more money than they actually did
that would attract investors way more so
that's exactly what they did from 1988's
towers financial corporation went on a
bond selling spree and instead of
showing investors the company's real
finances epstein and hoffenberg would
use all the debt they bought for dirt
cheap as their assets
for example they would buy a million
dollars worth of debt from a hospital
for fifty thousand dollars but instead
of listing the asset as fifty thousand
dollars on their balance sheets they
were listed as the original one million
dollars all of a sudden instead of
having fifty thousand dollars in assets
the company now had a million dollars at
least in the eyes of investors
it was a stupidly easy way to make the
company go from being worth a few
million to a few billion on paper and
let's face it most of these debts were
never going to be paid so in reality the
company was worth orders of magnitude
less than what our two ponzi schemers
advertised but people fell for it
epstein was too charismatic too cunning
too convincing and the reputation
hoffenberg had created for towers meant
everything looked very real it was a
match made in heaven using his wall
street connections fc so towers
financial bonds to anyone and everyone
over the course of six years the company
made over 450 million dollars from
duping investors in this manner and once
the money started flowing in the rest of
the ponzi scheme fell into place
[Music]
one of the first indicators that
something was off at towers financial
was the fact that stephen hoffenberg was
in charge of almost every position he
was the founder chairman ceo and the
president of the company in fact howard
didn't even have a financial manager
because hoffenberg was just that good
this also meant that no one was there to
oversee any of the financial decisions
the company made which meant that
hoffenberg and epstein were free to
pocket that money as they pleased they
would continue selling bonds to
investors based on those fake financial
reports they claimed to be collecting 30
of the debt they bought when the real
number was closer to 3
then they would use the money they made
from selling more bonds to pay back
earlier investors so the scheme kept
going and while doing that they would
make sure that a good chunk of it
disappeared into their own pockets
earlier investors were happy they were
happy and new investors couldn't wait to
get in it was an insanely lucrative
business and hoffenberg would use that
money to fund equally crazy spending
sprees he bought houses in manhattan
florida he bought luxury cars yachts
several planes at one point he even
tried to buy the new york post newspaper
neither epstein nor hoffman cared who
they were stealing from it could be
millionaires or 84 year old retired
teachers
they worked hard for their money and
they were gonna spend it and it was all
thanks to epstein's planning and
execution according to hoffenberg
epstein was the quote architect behind
the scam end quotes and epstein
allegedly made off with a hundred
million dollars of the money for himself
but then the sec got involved and
without warning just as the walls were
starting to close in on towers financial
epstein jumped ship taking his cut with
them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stephen hoffenberg had gotten a little
too confident and he attracted a little
too much attention by trying to buy and
save the dying new york post his knight
and shiny armor act attracted too many
eyeballs and one of those eyeballs was
the sec and they got to wondering how he
made his money it didn't take a genius
to figure out something was wrong and
from there things came crashing down
in february 1993 the sec began civil
action against towers financial
corporation and a month later the
company declared bankruptcy the feds
were onto him but epstein he was long
gone hoffenberg was the fall guy
everything got pinned on him epstein had
came in won his trust used hoffenberg's
company for his own gain and left it as
it was burning to the ground and for it
hoffenberg got sent to 20 years in jail
in 1997 when he was 52 years old he
wouldn't see the outside of a cell for
the next 18 years
in 2013 hoffenberg was released but up
until today he's still paying out the
462 million dollars or around three
quarters of a billion dollars in today's
money he owes to his victims
back when the case against towers
financial was still ongoing two other
high-level executives were sentenced to
seven and nine years for their
participation in the scheme but epstein
the architect behind the scam the genius
with no moral compass he wasn't one of
them
somehow he got away without a single
charge
from that point on epstein would use
that ponzi scheme money to slither his
way into the most powerful circles in
the world
eventually setting up his operation
where he would bring powerful wealthy
people to his properties to party half
underage girls there and record all
these powerful men with the girls via
secret hidden cameras and every time he
got in trouble with the law the same
pattern would play out he would be left
free without any trouble
it was almost as if he had a guardian
angel looking over him to make sure he
could keep doing what he was doing in
2006 epstein would get arrested on
charges of soliciting a prostitutes and
for procuring a minor for prostitution
magically he ended up getting the deal
of a lifetime but even the judge
admitting that he was told epstein quote
belonged to intelligence end quotes that
epstein's purpose was quote above his
pay grade end quotes and that he had to
quote leave it alone end quotes belonged
to intelligence huh
it wouldn't make sense hoffenberg did
meet epstein through a british arms
dealer and intelligence assets was apps
team really an undercover operative
getting blackmail material on the rich
and powerful for some intelligence
agency that is exactly what we go over
in our new feature linked documentary on
epstein called the man that didn't kill
himself which is out now and guys i'm
very proud of this one it's really good
all you have to do is click the join
button below to watch now because this
video would definitely get them
monetized if i published it and if you
join and don't think it's worth it all
you have to do is email me and i will
personally refund you the money plus
when you join you'll get access to our
previous and future private
documentaries coming out every month
click that join button below to watch
now
[Music]
[Music]
you